hello Kevin I'm married to Maria
Menounos you might need to take me
seriously Danny Daniels Ashley Daniels
her sister there they're all here
well me is it Danny oh yeah always be
recruiting Kevin I'll always be
recruiting welcome Keven Undergaro
Godfather's here married ship miss
everybody yeah
flew in just for this stupid event
tonight what are we talking about this
is epic
pretty stupid it's stupid and epic and I
just shout out to you know the
unofficial producer Chris the teacher oh
my god fantastic job behind the scenes I
understand yeah Chris is a guy who's a
fan of this show he's a bit of a
psychopath
and he's been running around bother you
called Greenstein yeah you know he he
talked to Scott Greenstein Scott course
was on board he took the call the next
time you have a lot going on and need to
and wanna kind of allocate
responsibilities to another person not
course the teacher okay you can tell
that you guys have been in the o na
world too long because you don't know
Howard you don't know the Howard
universe this is your sell the stock
broke Sal the stockbroker works for
Howard not originally due to Rossi Sam
Roberts too busy in ona world rob is he
was not he was broke he was a
stockbroker we ever teach you think you
think any no hear me out he was a
stockbroker he was a stockbroker and he
was a huge fan of the show he gave his
heart and his soul to Howard and then
Howard respond to it could create a
great entertainment still isn't got
hired so you think I'll call the all the
all the staff members of Howard show
were getting harassed by sound of
stockbroker going like you kidding me
Gary Dell'Abate you almost had to put a
restraining order on night calls what's
not like hey I booked some porn stars
you're like one up at events and you it
goes introducing me of NZ you did a
wonderful job on owene it was amazing we
want to go down that rabbit hole again
but don't let's just say it's the same
thing no you're coming to the gymnast
tonight right I can't I know Danny I'd
be too embarrassed to do it in front of
her Danny you should be there I can't do
in front of my friends it's too
embarrassing
it's an alter ego I know but it's
humiliating I have to do this [ __ ]
character tonight in the fish ball and
I'm humiliated at the prospect of
everything you know thought it was a
good idea to take fans and bring them in
to very high level responsibilities
Selena okay for period smashing checks
you know at the odd date is still doing
very well the Selena stateless you can't
go there you got the LA mentality where
it could I tell my Sam Roberts story
really that's super behind the scenes no
one knows about of course they're a hole
in the wall I think Jim noses
oh my god so I was meeting with Scott
Greenstein and I had my smoking jacket
on as we do in the the serious
Illuminati uh-huh and it was Scott know
anything about that mm-hmm
so Scott Greenstein it was Howard and
his smoking jacket and it was Sam
Roberts there and his smoking jacket I
forgot Knoll and one of the last things
I heard was I think it came out of
Howard's mouth he said you know I'm I
really hear that this I what is it my
wife hates me show I really like this
show and I'm actually thinking about
bringing on one on one
uh-huh and everyone nods you know and
goes along it was almost like that
meeting casino right where they put the
hit on the guy and then all since him
said you know I had some thoughts on
that show it's gonna work out so well
and then I walked out you're talking
about the serious Illuminati exactly and
this was the end of poor body and body
for accusing you of doing this but I was
there to see it now you've got your
three year contract so we can let
everyone know you know the truth that
yes it was part of the series Illuminati
and that I excused myself because I was
nervous and I was and soon after Maria
show was gone off a serious I am I'm
like you had me roped in that entire
time what did you mean Howard
I really am stupid ya know that yeah
yeah so listen we have all we have chip
glasses tonight that's all you know to
our select fans now
we have chip t-shirts oh my gosh very
exciting night we have a we have Santa
coming we have carolers we have a
best-selling author in the world of
Christmas I'm so sorry
kevin is a [ __ ] maniac you he did all
I did none of this [ __ ] I'm just gonna
show up here I'm humiliated BJ Danny I
would Kevin and I were both like you to
be there can you be there today yeah
Danny you need to be there what time
what time you have to be seven we
married chip misses at five oh yeah but
she has to prepare yeah I have to like
you got it all right Danny you've
already had Jim on right yeah can we
negotiate to have chip on I would love
to have chip on I'd be too embarrassed I
couldn't do it no you got to do it all
right we're doing you know I tell you
Danny you did make a huge impact on
Jim's life do you know this I do you
know my god that's right because of you
and your conversation with him
he now partakes in electrolysis of the
penis is that way his [ __ ] penis
Marie I want to talk about we get that
thing you dick wanded I got that from
her show yeah I don't even know if it
made the final cut we were talking and
Phoenix talked about like having these
gains wave sound wave shot into your
dick because it [ __ ] up the vessels a
little bit and then when the blood comes
in over the next couple of months and
replaces those dammit that damaged it
just kind of revitalizes you take it it
does a tremendous difference can you buy
that the show name oh yeah Danny dinner
with Danny it's on Amazon yep I'm in the
pilot episode and these are the things
we learn on that yeah yeah it's I mean
it's definitely not for the faint of
heart
no it's very dirty but really funny for
the faint of penis I mean it will hack
you'll learn something yeah so that's
what the show is talk show about sex
yeah it's me with some of my friends in
the porn industry and usually a comic or
a sex therapist or musician and we
pretty much sit around and tell war
stories how is rich Voss because watch
this dinner oh we gonna knock him off
seriously I mean off Amazon no - look I
don't have any power and Amazon mm-hmm
three-second positive it's like what did
you just say what did he say what you
gotta watch the show oh I would you
leave it in ya was wearing any fashion
accessories jewelry anything like that
maybe some rings anything a 60 year old
shouldn't be wearing yeah reading
glasses he left them yeah but did you
see all the rings on his oh yeah he had
too many right it's uncomfortable to
lighten the load okay does he usually
wear a lot yeah yeah he likes to wear
rings so that people know that
financially he's in really great shape
with them no no it's for financial
reasons right because his fingers are so
short unless his hands look like a
turtle and expensive shoes yeah he's
just at the table he brings up three CDs
they look the people on there like him
or no he's very funny so I'm sure he'd
be funny but he's very caustic you know
we do have a very important update that
we have to talk about there's a couple
of things and it's just been a busy show
there's lots that I want to talk about
with mark Normand but I feel like you
got here and then here comes George st.
Pierre in him you know jackhammer
massager and then Keven Undergaro and
then Mary chip minutes and Danny Daniels
but I'm mark by the way this is Mark
mark big fan nice to meet you we were
talking you know a few weeks ago about
your apartment you know getting
ransacked by somebody that your
girlfriend hired to rob it and you said
there is an update on the story of your
apartment getting broken into and robbed
in your sixty five hundred dollars in
cash being taken out of your inside job
yeah I don't know well they hit two
other units in the building
sixty-five hundred in his drawer yeah
they got a bunch of cash cash cash I'm a
comic so I just get paid in your
underwear drawer that's pretty my have a
cool guy drawer it's got a gun and pills
and heroin
yeah yeah you can put cash in the bank -
ah comics are allowed to have a safety
deposit box if you don't want to declare
it if you're afraid of that but I mean
just put the bank when you're not on the
radio what do you do for a living stamp
company what do you just have money in a
drawer or bank account you got some cash
keep all the cash in your house so we
all know I keep a little bit in my
drawer but I have less than a thousand
dollars usually ital this goes in the
bank it just it's just they pay a check
and I [ __ ] put it in serious money I
never see this money
direct deposit the problem is you want
to declare it know wasn't even that it
was just it was fun to have a big wad of
cash in the drawer declare it when we
got stolen and now he'll pay taxes on it
he doesn't have it so they this guy
broke in he jumped the roof this was the
cops found out jumped the roof and went
down the fire escape and hit three units
along the fire escape and I was the last
one okay and he hit a bunch of places in
Chelsea and they caught him Wow the guy
congratulations yeah so I don't know too
much about him he's 54 years old oh wow
and jumping 54 oh yeah did somebody yeah
that's something to look up to it quite
famous but they said he was experienced
because he knew what to take yes
so he's 54 cuz he didn't take any
marched electronic [ __ ] just took the
cash and got out you know fast in and
out fast yeah put a table in front of
the door so when family came in that hit
the table and he would be alert only out
right didn't want any confrontation for
years all these private doing this for
30 years yeah he knows how to get in and
out in and out but he's in jail now he
had a bunch of places he probably like
10 places what caught him did they have
a print no they just caught him in the
act and then they printed him and they
expect they had a print from here they
actually did have the print hey I think
the cops came in and printing my
apartment and they go oh I think we got
a print but they always say that just so
you don't kill yourself you know yeah so
turns out he was telling the truth
probably still has your 6500 I know I
was trust me at daydreamed all that yeah
it's my lucky 6500 I keep it in a
backpack okay she's taking - so how
would they know which is yours and which
is theirs I know and I could have made
up any number unfortunately did but I'm
sure he bought a bunch of angel dust
immediately right you have a career
you're a career robber you just go into
view you just rob people's apartments
and there's the it's the one it's the
one apartment to get you in the end he
could have been fine
he couldn't have tired as champion that
greedy they never print I never do no no
they never ever do and they never hang
on to their money either because it's
money to easily earn so they all blow
their money they write you know it's not
like it's worth it you know they're
putting it away and no your money is
gone oh yeah I'm aware cash check choice
yeah I'll check yeah yeah like a real
business person yeah I mean you don't
visit with you know that's all just
right in the bank stand-up the same
thing you can't steal money anymore
because the [ __ ] everybody's
declaring it especially a porn stars we
have a huge red flag like they're
looking at everything it's very funny
mark I got there I gotta use the bank
though I bought a camera but lakhs for
my windows I bought sensors and alarms
you did I went all out yeah you all know
that and then you're never gonna hear
did you get the ring though the ring
door ring doorbell I got the nest nest
cam which it just turns out it's just me
watching my girlfriend masturbate that's
the whole crane watching Godfrey LA so
bad with the robberies and there's just
there's not enough police to deal with
it yeah that it's at the point now where
with the ring you're able to talk to the
criminal oh yeah and they don't even
care they just ignore you and they laugh
at you is that right oh yeah they could
care less
oh you're wrong reason our neighborhood
and and nothing gets done you're on your
phone going great that's wild yeah man
but you might say you're feeling pretty
good I'm feeling great you feel like
there's justice in the world yeah but I
mean that's a big hole in the drawer but
I feel good I feel safe good you guys a
while after the robbery you feel like
vulnerable yeah he's gonna come in again
it's a bedroom window
it's the whole thing you own the
apartment oh yeah okay so yeah it's good
that you got it all done up with
security I guess yeah still can't get in
touch with my landlord why do you have a
landlord if
own the apartment well you know oh I was
super everyone was a super yeah yeah he
doesn't answer the phone
yes now I was trying to get him to put
bars on the window but he did like
though I don't speak English
does he speak English I'm sure he does
language what is it Spanish or Russian
and how many [ __ ] languages are there
I guess what I get a hire a guy to
translate now to find a friend he can
speak English yeah I'm sure he can get
the super good speaking of course I
didn't tip them Christmas last year so
what'd you put I put my Christmas tips
in today you have to oh really
you had the building will [ __ ] you if
you don't tip well I don't have any cash
that's true you should say that yeah I
had all these tips but they would take
it yes good good I'm so happy boss did
good I heard he was doing I'm like I
don't know that could be actually go
terribly wrong yeah no that's great
would you close would you [ __ ] eat any
the girls no he was I think the first
part he got a little nervous
I mean it's intimidating well my dreams
are not tamed so boss is a spitter no
he's not who's all of them what do you
mean uh that he was with yeah
oh no ok come back to that cuz I shot
five episodes this way so I'm like wow
what are the comedian's I know I've done
a Jeff Beach Carol Montgomery was on we
have shraddh small and I and then
Gilbert's our season Oh Gilbert's will
be great that'd be good that's great how
good was Gilbert I know I'm sure he will
all I want in life I'm bumping mics you
want him on that right he was amazing
Gilbert yeah he's so funny it's exciting
it's so good actually next week we have
it looks like we may have the stars of
bumping Mike's coming in to promote
their special Oh Jeff and Dave the
filthy brothers oh good yeah we're
working on it Chris Leitch I'm not
having them producers show promise I
won't even be just even a walk by those
two is scary they're my friends I
commend you for that but you can't
criticize I'm not having them work on
the show and like text Roy and be like
after the smashing success we have
tonight which we will I believe it will
be successful I hope so it's going to be
so bad we'll see
speak of the devil Chris the teacher is
on the
fun right now what what guy is like
horrified what's going on Chris he's
devastated
good morning gentlemen and lady how are
you doing today good Chris we ready for
tonight buddy I'm ready I'm just waiting
on a couple of things and then I'm gonna
make my way into the city I seems like
though you guys are all fully staffed so
I want to see if mr. Norman's maybe need
an assistant to watch his cool guy
drawer for him while he's away I'm good
I got the nest what is the network
between the nest and the other thing
well his yours is a doorbell cam nice a
camera okay yeah I assume I have a
couple it also nest does heating too
they can float your heat and a/c okay
get up to the thermostat helpful have a
middle-aged man around I got one app
that controls ever it's [ __ ] great my
TV remote everything I can turn the heat
up Chris do you think we're being unfair
um you I do because I was unaware that
you know I was supposed to be kind of
going behind the scenes and doing this
it was my own mistake I don't really
know what the business is or how the
industry works so the only person who
might kind of know what it is and well I
text the only person I know and that's
rolling and kind of got zero out of him
well welcome to the club yeah I mean my
only thing was that like first it was
like don't worry we're figuring out the
chip thing Chris is on it and I go okay
and then the next day I gotta here
here's here's the list that I heard from
Travis Troy handsome Rob rollin hot dog
all saying why is Chris text I mean what
the [ __ ] is he talking about
and I'm like night and I'm sitting
you're lonely I don't want to deal with
all this and why would we have Chris if
he's just asked why would we have Chris
do what the staff would do if he's just
asking the staff to do it you know what
I mean he's delegating Authority
that's all we don't need another
delegator listen we can always help
another delegator I appreciate your help
we're all due respect I didn't ask use
them no I appreciate you all right but
then I get a message from you yesterday
and you're in your little sad sack stay
calling like here's the list for
tomorrow actually take my name off of it
I'm just gonna drop off the stubble
leaves and I'm like Chris Christmas from
my wife I'm not gonna put up with it
from you why did you run that one by me
Chris I'm vetting all your stuff I also
I didn't I didn't reach out to Travis I
just wanted to get I thought I was
getting pranked I thought that this was
all and all yeah he did reach out to me
he did your honor forgot but no no it
was a fair question he just wanted to
know if it was if they were [ __ ] with
him like they did with hot dog he's he
is this legit and I said yes how many
people do you have to ask yes Travis yes
me yes Jim yeah I don't check Twitter I
check my Twitter DM z-- it's not like
after but I think I emailed you back or
whatever [ __ ] insurance it would have
been a great idea
would have been funny how do we get him
working on Danny's Amazon show Danny you
don't need it yes he makes it happen
that's producing you know who the most
annoyed person was try just grabbing
some you know Kristin I mean I like
Christopher like what the hell's he
doing yeah Trey's in the same school of
thought is me like we just don't have to
deal with all this nonsense and then all
of a sudden you got a guy going like hey
what about this yeah but he Chris got
things done Chris had something to prove
and he got things done what you done got
surprises coming tonight all because it
tries easier I'm gonna tell you
something what's that I'm terrified of
the surprises I am terrified though it's
gonna be their fight that's gonna make
the show maybe if there is there a metal
detector at Syria when you walk in Troy
you got any room on a trip to Boston oh
well we put chip on the ticket for 2020
for the presidency right you know it's
gonna be Chris the teacher that's gonna
be the one that's gonna quarterback
there no he's gonna be the one that
shows up in a [ __ ] military jacket
like De Niro
gives a six digit phone number yes shoot
me we do appreciate your help Chris
you're a good soldier thank you you know
that [ __ ] political career would
probably end like our blood Dwyers
though but let's hope so Jim certainly
is all right thanks buddy thank you
Chris yes we got it
you know he's helpful we got it I like a
helpful boy you do yeah yeah he gets
[ __ ] done he doesn't he has other people
did doing
yeah but then those other people said no
and he got it done yeah yeah our staff
didn't want to do anything I don't blame
them what they didn't want to do
anything Chris the teachers request
right like they're like why is Chris the
teacher asking me to do something
instead of like Jim for instance you
know what I mean I don't know put this
on you I'm just saying my event and I
have no idea what's happening I didn't
book anybody I have not written anything
for it I show up I totally trusted you
ever now it's your talent show Kevin ah
I trusted Kevin I didn't think it was
happening and then six days ago it was
confirmed it's happening yes and he flew
in which I thought was very nice so if
Kevin's bucking again on an airplane my
obligation is to trust me when I tell
you Kevin shows up you're you don't have
to think about it it's gonna be
spectacular people come in for chip and
you brought you this you're actually
commuters hi this is Ashley she
remembers better Elves tonight hello how
are you what do you what do you do you
are you work with Kevin marina yeah
works with us afterbuzz TV one of our
hosts moving to New York so you know
we're making some moves okay and but I
wanted to come in for the chip show
she's gonna help tonight Sam did you get
her a costume did they come to the
headquarters I'm gonna tell you
something you know what's arrived at not
Sam headquarters every day for the last
week uh boxes of stupid ship classes
every day and I don't know why
everything is just a hassle even the
littlest things Amazon is sending them
one pair of glasses at a time everybody
wants to know everybody wants her I got
I say a picture right I got home and I
had a pile of seven or eight boxes from
Amazon and I'd to open each one and each
one has one pair of chip glasses perfect
appreciate doing all this make sure you
bring them on
time don't be there don't be there so
you're moving to New York yeah that's
cool I'm single pick it up you can cut
the sexual tension with an oh my god
she's prime pickings because Ashley was
in a relationship for 17 years since
what seventh grade I've only seen one
penis my whole life actually I've seen
two but one I it was just somebody got
naked and I saw it Wow we should we
should bring somebody the guy that just
got naked or yeah guys all player now I
don't even keep plays for some team so
he actually junior his name was like
Tebow Joe no big penis allegedly hurt
yeah we went to BC allegedly no I just
went to BC but he works he Saigon he's
definitely the anything why did he get
naked
oh because we weren't like a party and
he just thought to get naked for a
second show you say a long time ago I
get a prom party for like it was like a
prom or some type of commencement ball
or something but still you saying the
guy you were dating didn't obey penis um
I'm not saying anything I mean I don't I
can't compare it to anything you hear
about to that guys from the NFL yeah I
didn't have sex with that or go near
that so once I have such a soon also be
able to be like okay can you show with
your fingers like like in terms of size
right about which one they wanted no
yeah the one you've had sex with yeah
Danny's right yeah yeah just tell me
when to stop
count they anyone to stop yeah yeah well
no that's too big Oh probably right
there that's not bad Jesus Christ why
are you looking at the pros about 9
she's wrong she's wrong guys 9 Oh
six seven is it really yeah oh god I've
been lying all these years when you
don't have sex to become a virgin again
how long since you've had sex like six
months yeah my hiny hymen grew back
you'll see a lot of dicks on the train
oh yeah that's true really masturbate on
the trains oh that's nice free
entertainment yeah okay don't I send you
penis pictures no I'm on a couple of
dating apps so they're like high like
high-end dating either they're terrible
first of all you cannot get like any
butterflies when you're like on a dating
exactly when do you get butterflies when
you're in person
ah same with chlamydia Jim do you find
the same thing like when you're in
person sometimes you just get
butterflies not only I know but it is
nice but like through text message I can
literally I can get so turned on that
I'm numb yeah so I'm numb I have the
text to prove it marks idiot cancer so
why haven't you gone on like penis
frenzy you know you're free your
vagina's free finally oh I know cuz I
feel like I need to be picky because
I've only know seven just [ __ ] everyone
yeah it sounds like serious management
like with these guys that are reaching
out to me on like dating apps and stuff
like I got a lot of booty calls I asked
Kevin I'm like oh so booty calls it's
like 11:30 at night like hey you want to
hang out and like wait who are you no I
think they're looking for really like do
you just literally show up and then just
write or do you think Troy that there
are girls that will take that and say
like oh they must be looking for a
relationship course sir
I don't know I know nothing like imagine
like a 13 year old girl who's no girl in
this world of dating and penises and I'm
just like and I went to Catholic school
my whole life told you
yeah I'm 30 okay Wow yeah you know you
got a starling dick pictures like just
started to see if there's anything you
like all right so I asked them for dick
pics
they'll-they'll offer somehow yeah we
have to start giving my number away then
cuz I keep on saying no yeah you got to
give the number I'm gonna give it out on
the air no ash what are you on Instagram
Daniels you how come you divert our
attention with a guy you as a guy why
didn't you want a dirty text Oh with him
I'm ang no I don't think so he's a
[ __ ] lame duck Jimmy when you like I
don't know what happened this guy did he
die very careful he's a big super agent
you don't been together since seventh
grade I can't believe they made it as
long as they did that's true it happens
like Mike Pence's wife if someone had
dirty text I can't do it I can't do it I
have to be able to communicate through
text you love the texting so much typing
though to it I lose some I blow it so
many times with girls I'm out with a
girl a couple of times I just blew it by
my texting I always do looking back it
up in person are you just like the text
guy no I'm not like I'm not bragging I
might um I'm gonna [ __ ] your brains I
mean I'm just telling them like things I
want to do do you get then do you do
them or is it just like sure cuz some
guys dirty texts and it's fantasy oh
well I mean it depends on what it is but
when you when you say you [ __ ] it up
is it you get too dirty or you just
sound ridiculous or both
oh yeah exactly they're not mutually
exclusive I just [ __ ] it up like what
do you say that [ __ ] it up um I don't
remember maybe I texted her too many
time I mean I'm really not obsessed with
texting but she was a weird girl anyway
but I was saying hey we'll go to dinner
and she goes I don't know
I'm like alright I just kind of took the
hit and said it's not a hint that's
direct message so I took the direct
message and I said take care and she
goes alright wish you well and that was
it that's good
I just you just wanted to [ __ ] did you
ever think about that if you saw the
interactions with no that's not what you
wanted to know I got more vibes when I
was fist bumping with GSP earlier now
she did not want to [ __ ] she'd want to
hold my hand in the restaurant why I
don't know that's that cool I wasn't
even thinking in my note I could see if
I was digging on my nose or doing
something I wasn't just didn't want to
that's not good date etiquette generally
good Ashley so you want are you trying
to jump into another relationship so you
got to get some of this strange dick out
there right I guess I do I thought we do
in between that's what I do
okay so do you need an Italian guy or
you don't care no I don't care how do
you feel about immature comedians I mean
I'm down for anything one wants to make
the person laugh I would like to be what
if I told you mean I knew a comedian
that not only would he entertain you a
very funny guy but you stick around with
them long enough he'll trust you enough
that you can get your friend to rob his
apartment and take off I am down for
anything right now I just want to have
fun and I just want to enjoy life and a
lot of catching up to do it would like
you would like it 15 years of catching
up to do I don't think that you know
what down for anything
yeah would you say that I don't think
you know what I'm hearing so I feel like
I would have fun being down for anything
do you mind if I throw back to Troy for
a moment sure Troy when you hear a girl
when you hear a girl she looks like
Ashley yeah gorgeous beautiful girl of
course and she says I'm down it is still
to meet you Aaron I do want you to be
aware
[Laughter]
but Royce
when a girl like Ashley says I'll I
actually really liked having sex I don't
want a relationship I'm down for
whatever and I just want to have fun oh
my god my wheel start I like picking
romance what does that mean I'm over
let's have fun I got it I got another
friend like in the mix I can bring you
seven the one you like or all of them
right right it's almost like Hanukkah
yeah yeah
does that sound appealing to you yeah
I'm really I'm not gonna say no I'm
really not
honestly I just feel like I know there
were some people that will just I'll ask
somebody something first like I'll go to
Kevin or like Roxy you might one of my
best friends and I'll ask them like is
we no Roxy yeah so as long as I have
somebody else that I ask just to get
their opinion on it right and for the
most part I know with both of them
they're gonna be like yeah go for it
then I'm fine yeah Kevin's a good one
for that Kevin's a good wingman he's not
gonna [ __ ] block no Kevin's a good why
Kevin's gonna keep moving forward right
right now unfortunately in this scenario
just because of timing Troy is actually
currently very happy in a committee that
recently changed
how recent what was a this morning by a
train as of yesterday well as yesterday
was deteriorating pretty fast
today it's that's that argument yeah
there's been one yeah
well listen we mourn her loss but we
wish her well now let's move forward
sure fun guys are the ones that are
emotionally damaged just so you know
it's called Edie the same a women though
the best abut most fun women Omaha
problems that's true oh yeah my
therapist told me it's a package he goes
that there's a package it comes with
this and this and this is the bad part
of the pack girlfriend told you it's a
package - I couldn't hear though my
faces in a pillow you take the [ __ ]
kinky dirty fun stuff is you seem fairly
stable for somebody who's in that world
that's my husband yeah I'm sure you're
not I'm sure there's major problems we
just don't say because although it seems
though Danny Daniels like you you've got
your [ __ ] together pretty well you've
got a lot of different businesses you're
making a lot of money you know crazy out
on my stands and then I try to hate Sam
right Danny Daniels Ashley grace Daniels
that's why I said they're sisters beyond
weird I didn't know I did not know I
could learn a lot from you know really
oh my god like it just so meant to be
come on Sam so when they ask you have
you ever no you made this happen I'm not
hooked up with a girl
no you no desire to know but I'm one of
my best friends I won't say who it is
but I've several best friends told me in
very much detail what it's like to do
that and it's like suction cups and just
like whoa suction cups is that right
Danny that's not the first thing I
thought of well I don't want that you
should try it you said you wanted fun
I'm sorry I just can't like the suction
cups of vaginas bumping together China's
touch each other why is that even
actually hooking up with another girl
yeah fun a lot of fun see you said you
wanted to [ __ ] me
I'm in the
two vaginas touching is like two old
ladies kissing there's no teeth right in
the mix yeah I think you gotta try
everything actually you don't know what
you want out of this life no right now
the only guys that have really been
pursuing me the most are like doctors or
lawyers and they're I just feel like and
one's a dentist and once an orthopedic
surgeon so it's like these people I
think they're like future guys but I'm
not gonna have fun with them right they
don't like Jews I actually love Jews
I've always wanted to be Jewish I know
that would we Jewish are Jason we thank
you Jason
you know I just saw somebody walking up
the hall who is also kind of in a place
where his relationship status is not
exactly defined and he might be a good
person to try to see if there's any
chemistry here how racist are you here
he is ladies and gentlemen he's a player
hott Dogg is here yes the mysterious hot
dog a real player yes Mountain a hot dog
I'm seeing the evolution of hot dog by
the way I haven't seen him in a year
we got finally got that going up to be a
fine young gentleman we got that haircut
fancy lad yes nice hey buddy
thank you so I like the federal owners
all even you like that yes I did jay-z
circa 2001 oh the ROG from what's
happening I see hot dogs I don't know if
you've heard do you know Ashley grace
Daniels no she's right there see you see
his eyes light up yeah I thought what
was your lows the first thing that just
occurred to you just now I'm just
meeting someone I know what was your
initial impression do you seem very nice
and lovely nice to meet you
Jess - now have you ever seen anybody
leak more platonic energy and your
design is literally the unsexiest thing
what about like a girl says all I think
it's sweet it's never her
it's really sweet energy not on me no
mercy leh come on well we're done I
don't want to know no idea what did you
really think physically you're
attractive looking lady but there's no
lady but that's not why you saw her it's
visual it's the first thing I thought of
quickly declining the first thing you
think of is someone attractive or not
whatever that's when you look at them
you just think worse especially the
opposite sex I mean yeah before I picked
him to do the show with more absolutely
you didn't go crazy so you think she's
not that I thought you were beautiful
thanks Jeff you're very welcome yeah no
I was happy to hear you're single wait
to hear see her in the chip elf outfit
we have tonight when she sees me in the
chip outfit Chyna shut yeah yeah so come
on you don't have a good rap hot dog
what the reason I brought you in is B or
we brought you in it's because Ashley is
single now she's out of a relationship
that she was in for what did you say
30 years six here no she's only ever had
one boyfriend she's only ever had one
man inside of her by the way that's not
a sexy stance you're taking hands in the
front pockets no hoodie pocket are you
waiting for your bus on the way to
school
I know but I see it on you trust me I'm
helping you but whatever what I'm saying
hot dog yeah is that a lot of the you
know hot dog is headed trouble we've
watched him get friend-zoned by just
about every girl that he's encounters by
the way two or three are we are we at
how many failures since the last one
I've only had one date so how'd it go it
went fine are we getting a second date
not this weekend or the week before but
May
okay that's a family so we're down to
watch that support you have to date my
brother just to see ya yeah but Ashley's
single I know that you're single because
the you know the girl that you're in
love with doesn't look at you that way
us dancer yesterday I did okay you know
the weirdest thing about Angie and Keven
you think this is odd too because you
followed this saga mark have you been in
here when hot dogs been in here before I
don't believe so I don't remember this
actually I think like once he's in he's
in love with this girl Angie and we talk
about it all the time but we talk about
it - hot dog you know what we found out
Angie has asked hot dogs specifically
hey can I go on the air with you so we
can talk about this on the show together
and hot dogs been telling her no no he's
doing no I want to know about it you
don't know about it and she wants to get
airtime exactly M for standing his
ground you know it's just like I so
[ __ ] up of our society with and of
course the show what like literally the
kindest most decent human being you
can't get any better than then hot dog
and the girls the best for him he's
[ __ ] why do you want to move to LA and
come work at afterbuzz I'd love to go
there
really yeah all right I'm taking him
your guy we have Anthony hit that he can
come in here and try to date Ashley for
Anthony unfortunately is in a relation P
copy that we'll find some other ingrate
to come in here hotter you can't get a
higher quality than give then then
hotdog then why doesn't Ashley want to
be with him that is correct so why is
the whole room everybody but me
I want to be with him you're talking
smack cuz you have the nice husband
that's standing by it's like here's the
issue everything you just pick on the
everything that you're saying right now
what applies to a 12 year old you want
to adopt him you want to take him there
to work you want to do this but it's
like a kid he's black defensive
hot dogs like in his in his late 20s at
this point wow you look great
it's amazing yeah it don't crack right
there's still a shot for them I mean why
not yeah it's a shy he's shy he's a
little shy that's all I heard his [ __ ]
is huge
I got his truck you know it actually is
true which is a bonus Troy told me he's
where was that packet packing a punch
she has a bigger penis than one would
expect that's true that's what I've
heard that's right that's what I've
heard but I've heard larger penis would
you date somebody like actually do you
think sure I mean I don't know I just
met right you I met you should say yes
she's beautiful of course they would and
then if there's been if it falls apart
and she's awful you just don't say it
sure yeah there you go
you don't want someone hesitant what you
want someone who's not hesitant project
player yeah yeah what does that mean
he's a racist development Oh
development squad well but when somebody
say only bad teacher Oh Sam what did you
just say about how to hook when he
walked in did you say he's developing
into an amazing young man alright and
what was he before trash with EMS before
know what we did that your studio a year
ago he was a staff or that carpet you
know him before that Oh hot dog were you
garbage yeah should he be talking to her
to get her interested in him great
questions Danny dick
straight to the dick pics that's what
she wants she wants to see more tix but
like if he were to just like I'm the
worst person asked how the [ __ ] I just
[ __ ] I saw like I have no idea but you
don't just show up and do it
I liked it a bit but how would you if he
were to walk in let's say you're not
married what would he have to say or
what type of thing when you have to do
to get your into pique your interest
don't say anything
oh just don't talk like that the
physical would be should be enough cool
girls know almost instantly if they're
into a guy 100% actually what kind of
what are you getting from what kind of
vibes you getting from hot dog in that
case oh not really any bit that's
because it's real a lot of room between
us and a lot of people between us it's
not his fault
he's three feet away okay they're saying
I couldn't be attracted to him because
there's three feet of rug space it's a
little bit like talking on the mic i'm
just being intense yeah all right so you
like glasses you think glasses are sexy
yeah yeah I think I think education is
really sexy to I've said give your
readers I do throw those suckers on are
they the purple you pink ones let's take
a look at those let's take a look at you
in those Joker's Jim let's let's get the
sex appeal going in here you know
sometimes I have to do live reads you
know to make the money
frankly with AIDS
Jim's glasses are good because they
perch right at the edge of his nose
that's where readers should be that's
right that's when I can properly read
the copy that's right and make that
money yes expects like now can we go to
look to please for your gonna rob me I
think you stole my money jump around
real Trayvon but yeah look commit hot
dogs to catch once hot dog realizes how
great hot dog is there'll be no stopping
him
he just got to get there he's got that
kind of you know how when somebody loses
a lot of weight and they get hot but
there's still a fat person in there like
Al Roker right exactly
hot dog is a mess in his brain still and
doesn't realize that you know he's got a
lot going on right now I know I'm a mess
you're not a mess bro maybe internally
he's a mess out outside he's a great guy
we love hotdogs but he's a little
insecure and he's not necessarily
reading some of these situations we've
done it I mean I'm a [ __ ] so you used
to be a mess hotdog you're not a mess
anymore you gotta break yourself with
that you're you you got it all going on
now you're the [ __ ] I'm trying yeah
you're killing it bro you're [ __ ]
crushing you look great huge dong thank
you is that true Troy always packing a
punch that's what I've heard
yeah you're you're crushing it on all
levels what do you like to do on a date
me yeah um I like I feel like dinner you
just eating I don't want to look at
someone eating I don't think it's very
appealing but you talk no I walk and
drink and I don't know you can go like
listen to music or I like for women like
the most scary thing is eating nice day
yes
did you take too many bites and be
dancing and I love a dinner date because
anything runs out you like alright you
look at the menu there's a few things to
break it up the waiter comes over right
guy sucks and now you're like just at
the you're just at the appetizer then
you do it like you know I'll just go
right to the main course you just go now
I can't I have to get up you always
build in an excuse before you go right
hey this is gonna be great
I gotta be done by 11:00 I'm getting up
early tomorrow and it's [ __ ] three
drinks are so much easier and then if
you like it you like let's get an
appetizer let's go sit down I feel like
committing to an entire dinner unless
you know you like the person I just felt
got so long I just like dinner and I'm
lonely yeah you wanna eat I don't eat
I've met anyway and how Bad's a bad date
gonna be if you're hungry and cranky if
I'm [ __ ] yeah and I'm starving I can
eat with anybody
exactly yeah yeah but you don't like
dinner date what do you like I like I
would only it depends if it's like a
first date I wouldn't like that but like
obviously like a third date or whatever
I would do that third a lot of work I
would definitely say a movie at some
point but I'd want to sit in silence
with someone yeah what if you go the
movie in use the movie talk guy oh you
can escape Danny are you assuming that
hot dog is a movie talker because if so
that's an ugly stereotype and you're
probably right that's too late or
something that [ __ ] facetimes at
dinner I've had that happen before
really facetiming at dinner what that is
great just a friend they answered a call
on facetimed it's it for America yeah
yeah even for a minute that's that's too
much that's a lot yeah it wasn't he was
like awkward before but that may not
talk word and quiet beforehand no we
were talking it was just one of those
species one of the table it just does
that like you know some people just do
it Wow
I don't know if I've ever facetimed
without having phone sex oh really
I almost never do it on skype I don't
like to hold my phone so I got a tweet
do levels you just said but even from
the beginning you just said I when you
said Skype you made a jerk-off gesture
like this is the universal sign for
Skype don't like when you're doing that
they're gonna screen grab it and just
like hold it against you I'm not
Danny are you ever worried that your
nudes will leak that's but no I'm not
you know what III don't people want to
see my dick [ __ ] let him I don't care
cuz I have a friend she's she's known
and she was showing me she's like very
sexual she was showing me like these
pictures she sent to this guy she
literally had her fingers in her vagina
Miley Cyrus and her vagina and she was
like gee I wonder good pictures it was
like I was like it's Julia Roberts no I
can't say but I was like she's really
hot and she was showing some really
graphic things at that moment and I was
just oh hey why are you showing me this
I didn't know if she was coming on to me
I had no idea but B don't you get afraid
like if you're in the industry someone
could just literally screen grab that
for a woman it's worse for me jerking
off on skype who cares what you're not
worried about your reputation being
ruined you don't want your family to see
that just a little embarrassing don't
you yeah but I mean mom mom would want
to look I'm talking to you can't let
your parents see cuz then dad will get
mad I'm talking to mom no but I don't
want it to leak of course nobody wanted
to but it's think that's gonna do ruin
me for jerking off talking great when
you're naked on the internet it's like
what do you have against me yeah exactly
make it on your bulletproof yeah right
anyway I mean I want to lose a little
bit of the guts you know then I wouldn't
mind you lose ten pounds yeah but I
still want to jerk off on camera yeah
right you be so skinny then you might be
so skinny well that's better though it
looks better yet ten pounds on camera
look great yeah yeah and when I shoot
you no no you know you gain weight you
gain weight in the in the dick gets
bigger yes what dr. Steve tell me okay
so at least I know it doesn't think I
heard from a jogger because your body's
yeah looks better the fat in the pubis
goes away I think that's what he's but
also no fat guys a lot of times have
that thing with their dicks just kind of
go in using that to of the pubis is just
all yeah
[Laughter]
you don't like micro penis no
uncircumcised I'm really afraid of that
like do I walk away if that happens [ __ ]
out of there
just ran it oh that is great for anal
because the guys pretty much as [ __ ]
his own foreskin interesting less
friction everyone I went to school with
did anal and we went to a Catholic
school and they just didn't want to lose
their virginity did you yeah you did
anal good for you actually why not it
was with one person but wait a minute
so if you do it I just got to do an anal
fun it still hurts to say that yeah why
not but I mean I think the whole like
uncircumcised thing I'm like very afraid
of why you don't have to peel our skin
down and give it a sniff it's so scary
I've heard it's like disgusting no oh my
god I've heard it's like there's dirt
under there that's gonna clean it like
it's like um foreskins are for losers
actually not what you do is you take you
take like a napkin and use roughly right
ahead
spray some Febreze in it yeah do you
want me you know you can get a little
shmegmer scoop we should invite that
tour to come in and I need you gentlemen
on clipped we have an experiment yeah
are you clipped yes you circumcised see
oh yeah I'm half
I left the top so I can just cover the
head in the Sun that's right better late
than never but yes we're all circumcised
yes yeah I wish I wasn't
what how'd you think sex just feel
better right mmm I think it would I
don't know I mean nobody came what can
you compare it to right you've know him
both yeah but my foreskin didn't peel
back so I wouldn't know wait what yeah
I've know yes we can't get into the
whole thing again
Sam was circumcised at 19 Oh because he
had better like in a hole a pinhole I
mean it was a little more as out of it
was like a pencil lead yeah so his dick
Lee skin which people wound up in this
helmet would always smell that's not you
don't know what it would smell of course
I do
do you think that you wanna you wanna a
mummified erect penis at all times you
want the flesh to just cover the whole
thing right who wants an exposed head so
you get some looks in high school and
stuff did you get a lot of grossed out
ladies I didn't get a lot of ladies I
didn't have that you see I didn't have
to deal with that problem still all the
guys I pulled you here's what his dick
look like your see
you're putting a turtleneck on the guard
on your head the hole would open that
far I told them I was a medium they gave
me a small that's what it was and when
it's pulled back your dick looks like
Steve McQueen
it's an old reference yes yeah but I got
I solved the problem that's the point
copper's oh yeah 19 tough time to do
that yeah did you ice it
well you yeah I mean yeah yeah you have
to you have to ICU I mean you're under
you you have to be put under to get the
procedure done right and then like you
know it takes a couple a couple of weeks
to recover and even then just for
everything to be normal it's like a
couple months you just be normal so you
couldn't jerk off when you were 19 for a
couple months for a couple weeks I
couldn't jerk off Jesus rough that's
what shooter comes in yeah yeah it was
tough Syracuse got lucky on that one
yeah
but I wish I wasn't any guys who weren't
its we had very different stories I went
home for Spring Break
you're not your unclipped that's diss
it's not too late but he wasn't proud
for a second he gave like a little
little little [ __ ] you little hey guys
be yeah I'm a natural yeah no it's gross
round get rid of it after you wash it to
get lint stuck in it no I don't do you
wash yes give us you make my scoop when
I was little my mom used to tell me to
pull back the skin Wow why would she say
that you'd be in the living room
[Laughter]
actually that's how you know he takes
care of himself his mommy told him to
pull back the skin yeah
mother said pull the skin back when you
were goddamn Hitchcock movie photo can
we see it I don't have a photo what kind
of a photo of his own dick I don't have
a photo either I'm married
yeah yeah but you've only been married
for a couple months but you've been how
long you been with your girl for over
five years okay yeah so you wouldn't
have gift photos the deck to feed I do
but I don't have any of my phone because
I had a girlfriend for so long oh I'll
have to put them back on
yeah you should reload them you didn't
did you no I have a couple of like the
the standard like the other one yeah
there's a couple of good ones and a
whole lot of duds is that right yeah
yeah
gotta get the angle right I'm shadowing
so go do a photo shooting you there for
six hours you only gonna use one shot
absolutely
I have an eagle in the background has to
look good
yeah because Rob's lens looks like a
pulled back dick turn it yeah it is I
see see the skin I see
I imagine you you've seen some it's the
idea of getting one sent to you it I'll
be embarrassed you know I'm because you
know some girl just porn is the same as
anybody else but I'd be embarrassed to
send a picture because what you're
comparing two professionals yeah oh yeah
it's expensive email older of just
really bad dick pics are they both oh
yeah you know it'd be great if I had my
Sam Roberts og dick pics where I could
send girls a picture of a wrecked penis
that's fully covered they'd be like what
the [ __ ] is yeah exactly they think your
dick is doing a perp walk you have a
bunch of bad dick pics that just means
small or is that just bad for sort men
yeah small hairy just bad bad lighting
uh weird sheets yeah bad feet oh they
get their feet and the shot is just
always I had a couple I always wear
socks I had a couple though where I took
her to the dick looked good through a
mirror but then I realized my bathroom
door is open you could see my toilet so
I had to crop it cuz it's the toilet
rekted
yeah yeah you don't want that you know
it's bad at dick pics Anthony Weiner yes
yeah when your kid is in the shot with
you you're bad at detail terrible
horrible bad angle yeah look at my bulge
this kid's one year old nice to UM to
pull the skin back I see I see
that make sense you have dick pics mark
oh yeah you do many how about you hot
dog he's got videos on oh that's right
sex videos that he's shown all of us
yeah threesome videos hot dog show Danny
Danny is a professional it's like
showing a doctor doctor yeah yeah take
the phone out I was about to say whip it
out but I don't know what hot dogs gotta
find a good one Grindr yeah yeah show
show your which video do you think
you're gonna show is it the threesome is
it I mean I only three so I only kept
one you deleted your videos [ __ ]
what's wrong with you
I kept one and it's not even a good
angle the only a lot the only time hott
Dogg has been able to reach climax is in
a threesome with another guy yeah the
truth Thank You true you were here too
yeah okay pump that volume up is the
volume all the way on that's okay I
don't like to hear a lot more Norman's
making I've never seen hot dogs penis
from you can't really see yeah this is
all a girl's back go back I don't see
any dick yet which is not a good sign
any hot dogs buddy yeah what are you
doing while you were shooting your
friend getting blown shooting on your
computer open it with VLC I'd [ __ ]
lightning your friend your friend no so
angry I know alright also know music how
would you feel getting hot dog show
uncle Arthur Bakshi a picture of like
the best dick you've ever seen my
husband's of course not your good answer
Rob can you take hot dogs videos brought
into Adobe for some part correct yeah
yeah we're gonna do a little color
correcting disturbing you think an Isis
video mark
yeah yeah you're talking to that dog are
you playing something Christmas music
exactly he likes to play the tunes hey
get down
he likes reggaeton it was baby it's cold
outside honey would you pull up the
video of you and your ex you don't have
it every day she made me delete it she
didn't pull it up hot dog you're being
an ass you going to your recently
deleted videos you rookie and you put it
back what's the matter with you I'm
gonna show people how to be devious I
deleted out the 30 days and it's been
like two years pull it up on the Dropbox
they uploaded it to where is it your
homework go home tonight maybe it's in
the cloud I don't know there's evidence
the Troy saw that you're packing a punch
Danny's in here now she wanted to see
she has friends who knew she could hook
you up when we broke up and show you go
do me a favor as we asked me to delete
the video that I have here can you
delete all your sex videos sure [ __ ]
crazy listen to that request Ashley does
your ex have sex videos of you know you
did anal but no snow videos video dirty
pictures no so don't put your face in my
most my dick photos dawg I only did one
I
I took one recent with my face in it but
I don't see you face you don't put your
face in it that's a woman I wanna see
your dumb face especially yours I know
trust me I know what my Ruby spots are I
mean that was in high school we were all
doing that in high school anal yeah I'm
Catholic school sure I went to Catholic
school yeah yeah twenty girls and they
were all just very horny we do you know
were you afraid you might have an
accident doesn't like the but not count
to Jesus yeah I mean for them for me I
just was like I'll try it but I already
had heads but you didn't have any
moments that we like oh it's tops up no
I did you just get used to it then you
just end up liking it I see at some
point but that you stop then you hate it
again any messy scenarios no nothing
look at you yeah you Boston
yeah Boston girls with a [ __ ] best
you like that says yeah
best yeah how often would you do that in
your relationship have we've only done
it a few times we had done it like maybe
five times celebrations totally
celebrations and promotions work
promotions Boston girls are the best
yeah Oh Catholic school girls but
they're dirty
yeah just the opposite like Philly girls
I don't like Boston Philly they stink
they do nothing
yeah but they don't [ __ ] I disagree
maybe they [ __ ] you they don't [ __ ] me
let me make my statement watch the time
they don't [ __ ] me
I don't think Philly is the problem no
boy I'm batting 720 in Boston Wow
interesting [ __ ] that whole shitty
accent anybody with that accent will
[ __ ] me the more you get to the North
Shore area that's where it's more I like
dirty said the best